.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Das Paradies -
es kann auch so aussehen.
Das Oberwallis mit
dem boomenden Industriestandort Visp.
Derzeit ziehen jeden Monat
Dutzende neue Arbeitskräfte
aus aller Welt hierher -
die meisten zum Pharmakonzern Lonza.
How are you?
Hallo, ich bin Fabienne und bin
in diesem Paradies aufgewachsen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ziel der Walliser Promotoren ist es,
Fachkräfte in den Kanton zu bringen
und dabei mitzuhelfen, dass diese
sich hier wohlfühlen und bleiben.
Danke euch. Wir sind so glücklich,
euch hier zu haben.
Geniesst es, trefft Menschen,
macht das Beste daraus.
Willkommen im Wallis.
Willkommen im Paradies.
Das Oberwallis - bisher gingen
viele Menschen eher weg von hier,
für die Arbeit oder fürs Studium.
So wie ich vor 30 Jahren.
Ich frage mich: Was für Leute sind
das, die jetzt ins Wallis kommen?
Und was wird dafür getan,
damit sie hierbleiben?
Singapur - der asiatische Stadtstaat
mit knapp 6 Mio. Einwohnern.
10'000 km von Visp entfernt.
Bis hierher
drang der Lockruf aus dem Oberwallis.
* Sie unterhalten sich auf Indisch. *
Familie Mhamane ist am Packen.
Yes?
- No, this is mine.
Where is your jacket?
- On this side.
Es ist Mitte Juni.
In sechs Wochen
werden sie die Zelte hier abbrechen
und in die Schweiz reisen.
Oh look, so soft.
Wichtig für sie:
die neue Winterkleidung.
Hier in Singapur, wo die Temperaturen
selten unter 25 °C liegen,
haben sie so etwas
noch nie gebraucht.
Put the jacket in.
Die Schweiz sei ein sehr kaltes
Land, sagen meine Kollegen dort.
Da sind unsere Kleider von hier
nicht passend.
Sie haben mir empfohlen,
warme Kleider zu kaufen:
Jacken, lange Hosen usw.
Die Kälte
ist im Moment unsere grösste Sorge.
Wenn wir uns
an die Temperaturen gewöhnen können,
wird alles gut.
Wir wollen lange
in der Schweiz bleiben.
Murlidhar und seine Frau Pallawi
stammen aus der Mumbai-Region
in Indien.
Ihre Eltern sind Landwirte.
Sie haben die Heirat arrangiert.
Seit acht Jahren wohnt
das indische Paar aber in Singapur.
Pallawi ist Hausfrau.
Ihr Mann Murlidhar
arbeitet als Produktionsspezialist
bei Lonza Singapur.
Jetzt hat er die Chance,
in der gleichen Funktion
ins Wallis zu wechseln.
Es ist ein Traumjob für mich.
Die Schweiz wird Stabilität
und mehr Möglichkeiten
in unser Leben bringen.
Nicht nur für mich,
sondern auch für meine Kinder.
Darum gehe ich dorthin.
Das ist die grösste Motivation.
Dass meine Kinder eine gute Aus-
bildung und eine gute Zukunft haben.
Die Schweiz kennen sie v.a.
aus den indischen Bollywood-Filmen.
In unserer Anwesenheit sprechen sie
meistens Englisch zusammen.
Aber eigentlich ist ihre
Familiensprache das indische Marathi.
Jetzt heisst es, Deutsch lernen.
(Kinder) Quiz.
- (Quizstimme) Just like in English.
Die Couch.
- (Pallawi) Couch.
The next one is for you.
This one?
- Deutschland.
Deutschland.
Deutschland is Germany.
Okay.
(Quizstimme) G ...
- Gitarre.
Gitarre.
(Quizstimme) H ...
- (Kinder) Haus.
As it would be in English.
- Haus.
It's just "u" and not "ju".
V ...
- Vogel.
Die Ortschaft Visp sei ein gutes,
kleines Städtchen im Kanton Wallis.
Ist das richtig? "Wallis"?
Meine Freunde sagen,
man finde dort alles.
Es sei aber viel weniger bevölkert
als Singapur.
Ruhig und friedlich.
Die Leute arbeiten dort
nur von 8 Uhr bis 17 Uhr.
Nach 18 Uhr arbeitet niemand mehr.
Darum muss man zu Hause bleiben.
Es habe keine Leute mehr draussen.
Das macht uns etwas Angst,
v.a. meiner Frau und den Kindern.
Aber samstags und sonntags
werden wir Ausflüge machen
und viele neue Dinge
entdecken können.
* Melancholische Musik *
Eigentlich
seien sie in Singapur glücklich
und hätten einen guten Freundeskreis.
Aber als Inder hier eine ständige
Aufenthaltsbewilligung zu erhalten,
sei äusserst schwierig.
Da seien die Chancen
in der Schweiz besser, glauben sie.
Damit
könne er insbesondere seinen Kindern
stabile
und sichere Perspektiven geben ...
... und ihnen Europa eröffnen.
In der Schweiz gibt es
noch viel grössere Seen als diesen.
Und es gibt gute Züge,
wie in Singapur.
Aber sie haben dort
keine so grossen Shoppingcenter.
Daran müsst ihr euch gewöhnen.
Gibt es keine Milch?
- Doch, natürlich gibt es Milch.
Es gibt Kühe in der Schweiz.
Wir kaufen dir eine.
Im Wallis
gibt es gleich mehrere Grossprojekte,
die auswärtige Fachkräfte erfordern.
Man spricht von 4'000 Stellen.
Am meisten Personal
braucht die Lonza,
die im Biotechbereich u.a. den
Covidimpfstoff Moderna fabriziert.
Viel zu tun
für Personalchef Giovanni Gallo.
Gallo ... Sind Ihre Eltern Italiener?
Wann kamen sie in die Schweiz?
Die kamen 1965.
- Aha.
Also, meine Mutter kam 1958
und mein Vater 1964.
In die Lonza?
- Ja.
Wir waren Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge.
Sie hatten in Sizilien keine Arbeit.
Und in dieser Zeit kam mein Vater
als Schlosser zur Lonza.
Er lernte meine Mutter
hier in Visp kennen.
Aber beide stammen aus Sizilien.
- Ah ja?
Gehen Sie
nach Sizilien in die Ferien?
Nein, nein, das ist zu weit weg.
Haben Sie dort keine Familie mehr?
- Doch, doch.
Aber wir gehen nicht jedes Jahr hin.
Als Kinder
waren wir jeden Sommer dort.
Ah ja?
- Ja, ja.
Vier Kinder, Koffer auf dem Dach.
- Ehrlich?
(Lachend) Wie man es kennt.
Aus rund 60 Ländern
arbeiten Angestellte in der Lonza -
am meisten aus Deutschland
und Österreich.
Ihnen gelinge die Integration
einfacher.
Wer nur Englisch spreche,
habe es schwerer.
Manche klagen darüber,
dass sie schwer Kontakt fänden.
Da arbeite man dran,
sagt der Personalchef.
Unsere Aufgabe als Arbeitgeber
ist es, sicherzustellen,
dass die Mitarbeitenden,
die von überall herkommen,
sich hier wohlfühlen,
sich integrieren
und dass sie ihre private und be-
rufliche Zukunft in der Lonza sehen.
Dass sie Walliser werden.
- Ja, warum nicht?
Das gab es
in der Vergangenheit auch schon.
Viele Mitarbeiter aus dem Ausland
wurden dann Schweizer.
Sie übernahmen auch Aufgaben
in der Gemeinde.
Das wollen wir weiterführen.
Zentral sei die Sprache.
Darum sind Deutschkurse Pflicht.
Besonders Motivierte wagen sich
sogar in den Walliserdeutsch-Kurs.
Hier sind es Deutsche,
Westschweizer und Belgier.
Ich fange mal an.
Ich heisse Felizitas Berchtold.
Ich komme aus Visp.
Ich wohne in Naters und arbeite
als Lehrerin bei Academia.
Der Übertitel heisst ja
"Walliserditsche Gwunder".
Wisst ihr, was "Gwunder" heisst?
"Walliserditsche Gwunder"
heisst "Walliserdeutsche Neugier".
Kannst du das vorlesen?
"Im Glanz fa der Kutsche
bringunsch z'Gepäck."
"Schi hänt flotti Chleider,
ganz süberi, wiä gschläckt."
Wie ein Walliser.
"Und alli sind zfridu,
die Herrschafte öi."
Sehr gut.
Jetzt kommen die weniger schönen.
Was bedeutet "Göich" und "Tampa"?
Ein Idiot.
- Manchmal sagt man das auch,
wenn jemand einen Witz macht:
"Bisch en Göich!"
Und eine "Tampa"?
Die weibliche Form.
Eine blöde Kuh.
Jetzt kommt noch ein ganz lustiger:
"Brüchsch en Tritt ins Fittla?"
"Brauchst du einen Tritt
in den Allerwertesten?"
Das bedeutet:
"Brauchst du Motivation?"
Aber genau übersetzt ...
Den Chef würde ich nicht fragen:
"Brüchsch en Tritt ins Fittla?"
Das sagt der Chef zu Ihnen.
- Wie?
Das sagt er Ihnen.
- Genau.
Sie machen v.a. mit,
um es verstehen zu können.
Damit sie
nicht immer nachfragen müssen.
einfach etwas mehr verstehen.
Es klingt merkwürdig, wenn man
angestrengt zu reden versucht.
Wenn sie an der Kasse
"Ade, merci" sagen können,
oder "Tschau zämo" oder "Gäh wer
eis ga zieh?", ist das schon viel.
Ich habe euch versprochen,
dass wir in der letzten Stunde über
Walliser Spezialitäten sprechen.
Kennst du etwas, das man hier isst?
Das mit dem Käse kennst du sicher.
Aber ich habe den Namen vergessen.
- Gut. Raclette.
(Alle) Gesundheit.
Sprechen ist schwierig.
Verstehen ist deutlich einfacher.
Aber es ist
nicht nur in Meetings hilfreich,
wenn man mehr versteht.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Und selber sprechen?
- Man versucht es.
Gib mir noch ein Jahr.
Die neuen Stellen
werden in der Talebene geschaffen,
aber sie eröffnen
auch oben am Berg neue Chancen.
Auch für Andreas Imstepf.
Er arbeitet selber
seit Jahren bei der Lonza.
Zugleich ist er Gemeindepräsident
des 300-Seelen-Bergdorfs Zeneggen.
Haben Sie schon mal
so etwas wie jetzt erlebt?
Nein, im Moment haben wir in Visp
Goldgräberstimmung im Quadrat.
So etwas habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Früher ging man
in der Lonza-Kantine essen
und kannte sehr wenige nicht.
Wenn man heute dort essen geht,
kennt man nur wenige.
Die Zuwanderung ist extrem.
Besteht jetzt die Hoffnung,
dass Zeneggen auch etwas abbekommt?
Das ist natürlich unsere Hoffnung.
Wir brauchen unbedingt
neue Einwohner -
v.a. neue Schulkinder, damit wir
die Schule erhalten können.
Damit sich aber
Familien niederlassen,
braucht es geeignete Wohnungen
und ausserschulische Kinderbetreuung.
Daran fehlt es noch.
Aber es gibt Hoffnung:
das private Grossprojekt
eines Einheimischen.
Hier rechts gäbe es die Überbauung.
Da wären in der Ecke drei Häuser
mit je vier Wohnungen - also zwölf.
Hier wären noch zwei,
auch je wieder mit vier Wohnungen.
Das gibt 20. Und hinten nochmals ...
Es gibt 27, 28 Wohnungen.
So viele?
- Ja, ja.
Und da käme auch die Tagesschule
bzw. die Kinderbetreuung hinein?
Genau.
Nachschulbetreuung heisst das.
Genau, die käme hierher.
Das wäre eine Wohnung hier.
Die Bevölkerung muss zum Kauf
dieser Wohnung aber noch Ja sagen.
Das Zentrum.
- Ja, das kann man sagen.
Downtown Zeneggen.
- Genau.
Hier sind die Kirche
und das Schulhaus.
Hier rechts?
- Jawohl.
Hintendran
ist direkt die Mehrzweckhalle.
Das ist das Pfarrhaus.
Unten sind ein Laden
und ein Bistro drin.
Ich stelle das Auto mal hier ab.
Ist das das Schulhaus?
Ja, das ist das Schulhaus.
Das ist stark gefährdet.
Gefährdet ist die Schule,
weil es ab nächstem Sommer
in der Oberstufe zu wenig Kinder hat.
Mindestens sieben sollten es sein.
Ohne Zuzüger
kommt man in den nächsten zwei Jahren
nicht auf diese Zahl.
Dann will der Kanton
die Oberstufe schliessen.
Wenn nur noch die Unterstufe bleibt,
sei die ganze Schule gefährdet,
das habe die Erfahrung
in anderen Dörfern gezeigt.
Dann müssten alle Kinder
ins Tal nach Visp in die Schule.
Eine schlechte Entwicklung
für das Dorf.
Jene nach Visp zu schicken,
die schon hier sind, das geht.
Das grösste Problem sehe ich darin,
ohne Schule
neue Familien anzulocken.
Darum sage ich,
dass der Berg dann stirbt.
Dann ist das hier
eine Alterssiedlung.
Wer hier ist, ist hier,
es kommt aber niemand mehr.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Zürich Flughafen,
der 1. August, frühmorgens.
Der Inder Murlidhar und seine Familie
sind aus Singapur angekommen.
Mit dem Zug geht es
in Richtung Wallis bis nach Brig.
Ist das Monsunregen?
- Nein, es regnet nur heute.
Die Züge sehen aber ähnlich aus
wie in Singapur.
Das ist eine Kirche.
Schau mal die Kirche. So schön.
Und der Fluss und die Busse.
This one. Bus, bus. It's a bus.
See?
Das ist aber eine grosse Stadt.
Brig oder Bern? Bern, glaube ich.
Wir fahren bis nach Brig, ja?
Ich brauche Milch für die Kinder.
Es gibt nur ein kleines Geschäft,
das offen hat.
Ah, a little one.
Ach so?
Ja, das müssen wir uns merken.
Hier ist es nicht wie in Singapur.
Am Wochenende geniessen die Menschen
hier das Leben.
Es ist nicht immer
nur Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit.
Es ist ausgeglichener.
In Singapur
sind die Läden 24 Std. am Tag offen.
So viele Einkaufscentern.
Hier ist alles anders.
Aber wenn man gerne Ruhe hat,
ist das hier ein guter Ort.
Da gehen wir dann zusammen hoch.
Ich glaube, ich gehe einen
ganzen Monat nicht mehr aus dem Haus
oder ein ganzes Jahr.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
(Durchsage) Nächster Halt: Visp.
* Sie unterhalten sich auf Indisch. *
One, two, three, four, five, six.
- Six.
(Frau) On the screen. Do you see?
Hello?
- Yes?
On the screen.
- This one?
Yes.
No, that one.
- Ah, press this one. Okay.
Gereist sind sie mit neun Koffern.
Let's go.
Alle Möbel und der restliche Hausrat
folgen in einem Container übers Meer.
Die Temperatur heute: rund 15 °C.
Wait for me.
Gepäckwagen finden sie keinen.
Und auch mit dem Taxi
klappt es nicht.
Schliesslich fahren sie mit
dem Ortsbus in die Gemeinde Naters.
Gut 20 Std.
hat die Reise insgesamt gedauert.
One, two, three.
Ich bin so müde.
- Ich bin auch müde und ich friere.
Die Wohnung, die sie hier beziehen,
ist nur eine vorübergehende Bleibe.
Etwas Passendes zu finden
ist im Walliser Talgrund
aufgrund der grossen Nachfrage
gar nicht mehr so einfach.
Murlis Betreuer,
von der Lonza zur Verfügung gestellt,
suchen noch.
Die Arbeit wird sich
nicht so stark unterscheiden.
Ich bleibe ja in der gleichen Firma.
Aber ich muss mir jetzt überlegen,
wie es mit der Familie weitergeht.
Wo wohnen wir?
In welche Schule
werden die Kinder gehen?
Aber die Leute von der Lonza
helfen mir.
Sie kümmern sich um viele Details.
Die ersten Schritte
in der neuen Heimat.
Ihr habt Vortritt hier.
Ihr kommt zuerst, nicht die Autos.
Wenn ihr geht, muss das Auto warten.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Montag und Samstag.
Monday to Friday.
- Saturday and Sunday it's closed.
It's Sunday. So tomorrow it's open.
Wohnen Menschen hier drin?
It's really nice.
Ist das hier ein Tempel?
Beim Eintreten in die Kirche wollen
beide zuerst die Schuhe ausziehen.
In den indischen Hindutempeln
mache man das halt so.
Ein Stossgebet
nach einer langen Reise.
Im Bergdorf Zeneggen
ist heute Urversammlung.
Das Volk entscheidet,
ob die Gemeinde
die neue Wohnung für die
Nachschulkinderbetreuung kaufen soll.
Jetzt ist unser Parkplatz weg.
- Die Leute sind schon da.
Es ist gerade Messe.
- Ah, Messe.
Die Versammlung
findet immer nach der Messe statt.
Sie kommen von der Messe
an die Gemeindeversammlung.- Mhm.
Das ist praktisch.
Von einer Predigt zur nächsten.
- Ja, genau.
Detlef.
Guten Tag, Präsi.
- Ja, sali.
Ich habe schon kurz gegoogelt.
Darf man so?
- So ist gut.
Wie geht es?
- Gut. Man überlebt es hier.
Wie erging es
dem ersten Deutschen in Zeneggen?
Bin ich der erste Deutsche?
- Ja ...
Sicherlich einer, der geblieben ist.
- Genau.
Es lässt sich gut leben.
Ich habe es überlebt.
Ich kam her, als ich die Zusage
von der Lonza erhalten hatte.
Ich hielt es 30 Jahre
in der Lonza aus.
Ich bin seit acht Jahren
pensioniert.
Zeneggen war eine kühne Wahl.
Vor meinem ersten Tag in der Lonza
kamen wir hierher.
Es gefiel uns von Anfang an hier.
Wir kauften direkt ein Haus -
eine Wahnsinnstat.
Wir folgten unserem Bauchgefühl.
Aber es hat sich gelohnt.
Was hat das Bauchgefühl gesagt?
Da waren einmal die Berge,
die Natur ...
Und auf den zweiten Blick
war ich überrascht vom Dorfleben.
Das kann man nicht von Anfang an
richtig einschätzen.
Das war ganz cool.
Wir kamen mit drei Kindern.
Es hiess damals,
wir hätten die Dorfschule gerettet.
Ihr hattet doch nur ein Kind.
- Nein, zwei.
Und das dritte
wurde kurz danach geboren.
So habt ihr die Schule gerettet?
- Das war so.
Es bräuchte noch einmal einen Detlef,
um die Schule zu erhalten.
Die Frage
der ausserschulischen Kinderbetreuung
ist ziemlich neu für das Dorf
und sie bewegt die Gemüter.
Danke, dass ihr so zahlreich
erschienen seid. Das freut mich.
Die Gemeinde braucht Räumlichkeiten,
um ein attraktives Angebot
für die ausserschulische Betreuung
anbieten zu können:
Vor- und Nachschulbetreuung,
Mittagstisch, Spielgruppe -
die Bedürfnisse werden in den
nächsten Jahren sicher zunehmen.
Die Wohnung in den Steiachero ...
Das ist jene Wohnung,
von der wir finden,
dass sie am besten geeignet ist.
Es ist eine Parterrewohnung.
Man kann also draussen
auch Spielplätze machen.
Die Finanzierung:
Die Gemeinde kauft ohne Hypothek.
Die Urversammlung muss dem vollen
Betrag von 792'000 Fr. zustimmen.
Fragen? Meinungen?
Wir brauchen so eine Struktur
der ausserschulischen Betreuung -
und zwar sofort, jetzt.
Ich finde, wir haben hier
das Angebot direkt vor unserer Nase:
das Pfarrhaus.
Der Gemeinderat
hat bis jetzt gesagt,
man müsse mit dem Geld
haushälterisch umgehen.
Das habt ihr in den letzten Jahren
vorbildlich gemacht.
Jetzt wollt ihr das einfach ausgeben
und wegwerfen.
Überlegt euch das.
Was für den Erwerb der Wohnung
spricht:
die neuen Fachleute,
die zur Lonza stossen.
Das sind normalerweise
Akademikerfamilien.
Da werden enorm viele
Kinderbetreuungsplätze gesucht.
Das kann im Tal
wohl nicht geboten werden.
Das ist unsere Chance,
junge Familien anzulocken.
Wir sollten diese Chance
jetzt kurzfristig,
aber auch langfristig
und vorausschauend wirklich nutzen.
Die Wohnungen
sind einfach viel zu teuer.
Das ist ganz klar.
Und ich finde, dass es momentan
einfach nicht richtig ist,
dieses Geld auszugeben.
Ich bin absolut dagegen.
Es ist klar, dass die Schule
erhalten bleiben muss,
damit das Dorf weiterlebt.
Ich und viele andere
haben junge Familien,
die hier bauen wollen
oder das schon gemacht haben.
Darum muss das Dorf weiterleben.
Ich frage mich, ob man das
nicht alles kombinieren könnte.
D.h., die Gemeinde
kauft die Wohnung mit der Option,
daraus eine Kita zu machen.
Für die nächsten zwei Jahre
startet man hier im Pfarrhaus
mit minimalen Investitionen,
und dann sieht man,
ob es reicht oder nicht.
Die Frage ist, ob wir in die Zukunft
investieren wollen oder nicht.
Es gab viele Wortmeldungen.
Wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung.
Dafür?
Die Mehrheit
stimmt dem Kauf der Wohnung zu.
In dem Sinne:
Herzlichen Dank fürs Vertrauen.
Wir werden die Zusage machen.
Wir gehen auf diesem Weg weiter
und sind bestrebt,
das Angebot, das gebraucht wird,
auf die Beine zu stellen.
Danke.
Nach der Versammlung
spreche ich mit zwei Deutschen,
die seit Längerem
in der Lonza arbeiten.
Sie fühlen sich sehr wohl im Wallis -
meistens.
Hand aufs Herz:
Habt ihr Anti-Ausländer-
oder Anti-Deutsche-Stimmungen erlebt?
Ja, sicher.
Hier im Dorf ist das alles sehr ...
Wie soll man sagen? Sehr ertragbar.
Oder sehr moderat.
Aber sonst gibt es das.
Die Masseneinwanderungsinitiative.
- So was zum Beispiel.
Das macht schon nachdenklich.
Als die Abstimmung war, kamen wir
aus den Ferien über den Simplonpass
und da stand so ein grosses Plakat.
Es war nicht explizit, aber:
"Ausländer raus".
Ich denke, das ist überall dasselbe:
Alles Neue ist schlecht.
Man muss mit den Leuten reden
und fragen,
wo wir denn wären,
wenn wir nicht hier wären.
Die Lonza
bringt Steuern und Wohlstand.
Letztendlich sind wir auch die, die
viele Steuern nach Zeneggen bringen.
Das sind nicht die Bauern,
die hier wohnen.
Die Zukunft ist,
dass halt neue Leute hierherkommen.
Die Deutschen sind für die Walliser
jetzt wohl das geringere Übel.
Das Problem mittlerweile ist,
dass man nicht mehr Hochdeutsch
sondern Englisch sprechen muss.
Das wird
eine grosse Herausforderung:
die Leute schneller zu integrieren,
bevor eine Gettoisierung beginnt.
Eine Walliser Politikerin
hat mir gesagt,
das Oberwallis sei derzeit
innerlich hin- und hergerissen.
Bei Volksabstimmungen zeige man sich
oft noch sehr konservativ,
aber gleichzeitig versuche man,
Fachkräfte aus aller Welt anzulocken.
Der Inder Murli
ist jedenfalls definitiv angekommen.
Hello. Can I join?
- (Alle) Yes.
What's your name?
- Ich heisse Murli.
Nice to meet you. I'm Fabienne.
Where are you from?
Ich habe bis jetzt bei der Lonza
in Singapur gearbeitet.
Since when?
- Take your mask off.
Ah, kann ich die Maske ausziehen?
Ja,
acht Jahre lang war ich in Singapur.
Und jetzt habe ich hier
eine Möglichkeit bekommen.
Kamen Sie allein
oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich bin mit meiner Familie gekommen.
- Ah, Sie haben Kinder?
Wie alt sind sie?
Meine Tochter ist neun
und mein Sohn fünf Jahre alt.
Ah, sie sind ja noch jung.
Das perfekte Alter,
um Deutsch zu lernen.
Ja, ich denke,
es war die letzte Chance,
um mit ihnen
in die Schweiz zu kommen.
Bald werden sie wandern,
Ski fahren und Wein trinken.
Dafür sind sie noch etwas jung.
* Lachen *
* Entspannte Musik *
Es ist Sonntag, der 22. August.
Mein letzter Besuch bei Murlidhar
und seiner Familie -
drei Wochen
nach ihrer Ankunft in Naters.
Jetzt muss ich schauen, wo das ist.
Hier ist es. Hast du gesehen?
Auf der linken Seite, "Helvetia".
"Ausfahrt freihalten", ja.
Murli hatte uns gesagt, er wolle
heute mit Freunden Cricket spielen.
Hello. Morning.
- Hello.
How are you? Guten Morgen.
Hier ist etwas für die Familie.
Thank you.
- Sie sehen grossartig aus.
Sie haben das da auf der Stirn.
Ja, wir haben heute einen Feiertag:
Raksha Bandhan.
Das ist eigentlich
das Fest der Geschwister.
Für ihre Verbindung.
Meine Frau hat fünf Schwestern
und einen Bruder.
Die sind heute alle zu Hause
in Indien und feiern zusammen.
Das fehlt ihr natürlich.
Vermissen Sie sie?
- She misses them a lot.
An solchen Tagen
vermisst man die Familie am meisten.
Oje.
- Ja, so ist das Leben.
Ich habe
schon den ganzen Morgen versucht,
die Kollegen fürs Cricketspielen
zu organisieren.
Aber es regnet.
- You think you won't play?
Wir spielen heute wohl nicht.
Letzte Woche
spielten wir hier in Naters.
Mein Sohn auch.
Wir waren sieben, acht Freunde.
Kein Cricket -
aber Pallawi fragt mich, ob ich
an diesem indischen Geschwister-
feiertag ihr Bruder sein möchte.
Wer könnte da Nein sagen?
Ein Segenspunkt auf die Stirn und ein
gesegnetes Rakhi-Band ans Handgelenk.
Thank you.
Das solle mich
gemäss dem hinduistischen Glauben
vor Unheil und Krankheit schützen.
Jetzt seien wir Rakhi-Geschwister.
Danach das wohl schärfste Frühstück
meines Lebens.
Ein Genuss.
Meine Frau
muss halt viele Kompromisse machen.
She makes a lot of compromises.
That's why ...
In die Schweiz zu ziehen - war das
auch ein wenig ein Kompromiss?
A little bit?
- Not a little bit.
Nicht nur ein wenig.
Ich bin halt etwas traurig.
Ich vermisse meine Freunde.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich glaube,
es wird ein langer, spannender,
aber nicht immer einfacher Weg
für Pallawi und ihre Familie.
Das Paradies auf Erden
gibt es auch im Wallis nicht.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021